here's something laura has been telling
you about for weeks Democrats will be
turning to sexual misconduct accusations
who try and dump Trump now the
allegations of collusion with Russia on
going nowhere
but now the chatter and debate is almost
intensifying by the day let's discuss
that prospect with Erin McPike White
House correspondent for in the
Independent Journal review Erin thanks
so much for being here we appreciate it
thank you so we've heard a lot in the
last few weeks about President Trump
potentially firing special counsel
Robert Muller
the White House is vehemently denied
that claim why do we keep hearing about
it why do we keep hearing about the
white house going on this rampage on
Robert look you know I think a number of
Democrats sorry Kati I have an echo in
my ear
Democrats clearly want to see if that's
fixed for you Katie okay all right yeah
but you're okay you're gonna want to
right yeah I'm good okay all right do
you need the question again let's let's
change topics let's go to 2018 and how
Democrats are gonna play this we've
heard from the White House that the
president has no goals of firing social
council Robert Moeller despite those
claims we keep hearing from Democrats on
the hill that he might how was the White
House reacting to that and what are you
seeing on the ground going into 2018 in
terms of the strategy look Katie a lot
of the Democratic strategists that I
talked to do not want to be pushing
impeachment and that is because when you
look at the seats that Democrats need to
win in order to flip the Senate there
are a lot of seats that they need to
hold that are very red states that's
West Virginia that's Missouri that's
Indiana that's North Dakota and then
they also need to win a couple of seats
and that's in states like Arizona and
Tennessee an impeachment is not going to
play there the specter of impeachment
isn't good and independent voters won't
vote for that they want to see Democrats
really trying to go for things like
infrastructure and working with
Republicans on something infrastructure
chief among those they know that
impeachments not going to play you know
we are based in Washington I'm based in
Washington the momentum now is clearly
on the Republican side is there pressure
on Democrats to come to the table with
something in January especially when it
comes to big projects like
infrastructure I do think infrastructure
is the big thing but look tax the tax
reform bill that just passed is still
not very popular Republicans obviously
are going to be going on on a tour of
the country to try to sell tax reform
and Democrats have had the upper hand
there it did pass there is going to be
some momentum for Republicans but
Democrats want to keep that bill as
unpopular and their messaging has been
better for the last couple of months
than Republicans so they want to keep
pushing that message with the American
people what about the county's air in
the hundred-plus counties that switched
from Barack Obama blue to Donald Trump
red in the last election
how are Democrats starting those but
those voters and are they seizing on
issues like the economy where the
momentum is on the Republican side or
are they going with more of these issues
of sexual misconduct and the Moller
investigation and the Russia collusion
allegations I think the biggest message
that you will see from Democrats is that
they will say that Republicans haven't
kept their promise that simply that this
tax reform bill will add to the deficit
at a trillion dollars to the deficit and
that means that Republicans just haven't
been truthful with what they've been
trying to push on Capitol Hill I think
that it's gonna be a bigger message
sexual misconduct will play in primaries
sure it will be an animating cause for
Democrats with their progressive
activists and with women but I don't
think that's gonna be the biggest
message of next year what about the
numbers the the Republicans have very
little wiggle room when it comes to
passing their agenda in the Senate
Democrats who clearly have their eyes
set on the Tennessee Senate race they're
going after Arizona
how are voters they're feeling about
2018 and what are the big topics they're
you know Kate Arizona I think is the
biggest one Tennessee I don't think at
the end of the day will be in play as
much anyway what you're seeing from
Kyrsten Sinema that democratic
congresswoman who is formerly
progressive she's sort of moving into
the middle she's trying to cast herself
as a moderate she keeps saying that
she's not even gonna be talking about
Donald Trump in her Senate race that she
wants to talk about tax reform and about
infrastructure some of those
kitchen-table
issues that's obviously the big message
of the year yeah well it's going to be
an interesting 2018 for sure and I'm
sure we'll see you at the White House
and out on the road thank you so much
Aaron really shoot it thanks Katie